American Millennials spend more than three and a half hours
Thế hệ người Mỹ sinh từ năm 1980 đến 2000 dành hơn 3 tiếng rưỡi
On their phone every day.
Sử dụng điện thoại mỗi ngày.
A majority of that time is spent on social media.
Họ dành phần lớn thời gian cho mạng xã hội.
My question:
Tôi tự hỏi rằng
What benefits could you receive from stepping away from social media?
Bạn có thể nhận được những lợi ích gì nếu tránh xa mạng xã hội?
Would you be more productive, more focused?
Bạn có làm việc hiệu quả hơn và tập trung hơn hay không?
In what ways, might your life change?
Cuộc sống của bạn có thể thay đổi theo cách nào hay không?
And as someone who produces content and depends on an audience for a living,
Đối với những người sản xuất nội dung và phụ thuộc vào khán giả để kiếm sống
I wanted to know: Do you need it to grow and support your business?
Tôi muốn biết rằng: Bạn có cần nó (mạng xã hội) để phát triển và hỗ trợ doanh nghiệp của mình hay không?
So I quit social media for 30 days to find out.
Vì vậy tôi đã không dùng mạng xã hội trong 30 ngày để tìm hiểu.
The first few days were the most challenging.
Những ngày đầu quả thực là quãng thời gian đầy thử thách.
I knew without taking extreme measures, I would slip back into my old routine.
Tôi biết rằng nếu không dùng những biện pháp cực đoan, tôi sẽ sớm quay lại thói quen cũ.
Then check my phone frequently throughout the day.
Và kiểm tra điện thoại thường xuyên trong ngày.
So I deleted all social media apps from my phone.
Vì vậy tôi đã xóa tất cả các ứng dụng mạng xã hội khỏi điện thoại.
I logout all accounts on my computer
And cleared my history to build up some friction.
Tôi đăng xuất tất cả tài khoản trên máy tính
Và xóa toàn bộ lịch sử duyệt web để tránh việc tôi vô tình thấy chúng.
I was gonna do that anyway.
Dù sao thì tôi cũng làm điều đó rồi.
But that wasn't enough.
Nhưng chỉ vậy thì chưa đủ.
Like many people, I had hardwired into my brain this compulsive checking
Giống như nhiều người khác, não bộ của tôi dường như đã "ghiền" việc kiểm tra này
But it wasn't the content that I was addicted to.
Nhưng nội dung không phải là thứ khiến tôi bị nghiện.
It wasn't the likes, comments and DMs (Direct Messages)
Hay những lượt thích, bình luận và những tin nhắn trực tiếp.
It was the anticipation of what could be.
Mà đó là cảm giác mong ngóng những gì sẽ xảy ra.
Maybe that potential client messaged you back.
Có thể khách hàng tiềm năng nhắn tin trả lời bạn.
Maybe one of your posts went viral.
Cũng có thể một trong những bài đăng của bạn lan truyền chóng mặt trên mạng xã hội.
Or maybe The Rock tweeted at you.
Hay có thể The Rock đăng tweet về bạn.
The Rock, The Rock tweeted at me. Okay that one actually did happen?
The Rock, The Rock nói về tôi. Điều đó sẽ thực sự xảy ra ư?
But it's almost always nothing, so I knew I had to create some distance.
Nhưng tất cả gần như chẳng là gì cả. Vì vậy tôi biết rằng tôi phải để chiếc điện thoại xa mình hơn.
I committed to leaving my phone in the bedroom while I worked,
Tôi cam kết để điện thoại trong phòng ngủ khi làm việc,
And when I could I kept it at home while I left the house.
Và cất nó khi tôi rời khỏi nhà.
You know the classic triple pat?
Bạn biết quy luật vỗ 3 lần kinh điển chứ?
The moment right before you leave your house
Thời điểm ngay trước khi ra khỏi nhà,
And you check your phone, wallet and keys.
Và bạn kiểm tra điện thoại, ví và chìa khóa
Phone, wallet, keys
Điện thoại, ví và chìa khóa
I turned it into the double pat, just my wallet and keys.
Giờ đây tôi đã chuyển sang chỉ hai lần vỗ, chỉ ví và chìa khóa.
After a week, I stopped flinching for my phone,
Sau 1 tuần, tôi đã ngưng thói quen kiểm tra điện thoại,
And it no longer felt weird to leave home without it.
Và không còn cảm thấy trống vắng khi rời khỏi nhà mà không mang theo nó.
There are a number of reasons why you might want to quit social media.
Có rất nhiều lý do có thể khiến bạn muốn thoát khỏi mạng xã hội.
The side effects are a little bit different for each of us,
Các tác dụng phụ đối với mỗi người là khác nhau.
But I've got three main points that I think many of us fall into.
Nhưng có 3 điểm chính mà tôi nghĩ nhiều người trong số chúng ta đều mắc phải
Some people find that apps, like Instagram, put them into a "comparison mode".
Một số người nhận ra rằng các ứng dụng, chẳng hạn như Instagram, đặt chúng ta vào "chế độ so sánh"
By constantly seeing what other people have, you instinctively want it as well.
Bằng cách liên tục nhìn thấy những gì người khác có, bạn cũng muốn có chúng theo bản năng.
While others are addicted to the feedback and attention.
Trong khi nhiều người khác nghiện sự phản hồi và chú ý.
One study showed that many people would prefer a mild electric shock
Một nghiên cứu đã chỉ ra rằng nhiều người thà chịu đựng một cơn sốc điện nhẹ
Rather than sit alone in a room for 15 minutes.
Còn hơn là ngồi một mình trong phòng trong 15 phút.
Your phone can make you feel connected, less alone.
Điện thoại giúp bạn kết nối và bớt cô đơn hơn.
And it preoccupies your racing mind, and because of that,
Và nó cũng khiến đầu óc bạn lơ đãng.
It's a massive time killer that can distract you from your work and hinder productivity.
Nó thực sự là một kẻ giết thời gian khổng lồ, có thể khiến bạn mất tập trung vào công việc và giảm năng suất.
So when I started this 30-day social media detox,
Khi tôi bắt đầu cai nghiện mạng xã hội trong vòng 30 ngày.
I actually never intended to stop posting.
Tôi thực sự chưa bao giờ có ý định dừng việc đăng nội dung
Originally, for me, the negative side effects seem to only be boiled down to comparing myself to others.
Ban đầu, đối với tôi, tác dụng phụ tiêu cực dường như chỉ xảy ra khi tôi so sánh bản thân mình với người khác
And wasting time through distractions and browsing.
Và lãng phí thời gian vì phân tâm và lướt web.
And I wanted to see if I could get the benefits of using my platforms, like Instagram,
Và tôi muốn xem liệu mình có thể nhận được vài lợi ích từ các nền tảng tôi hay dùng, như Instagram hay không
To connect with my audience without actually using them.
Dể kết nối với khán giả mà không thật sự phải sử dụng chúng.
So posting through a third-party app.
Giải pháp của tôi là đăng bài qua một ứng dụng thứ ba.
But was that just me rationalizing my addiction.
Nhưng đó chỉ là cách tôi hợp lý hóa cơn nghiện của mình
Did I actually think that my stepping completely away from social media,
Tôi đã thực sự nghĩ rằng nếu mình hoàn toàn tránh xa mạng xã hội,
My entire life would fall apart and people would stop watching my videos?
Thì đời mình sẽ tiêu tan và mọi người không còn xem video của mình nữa?
Did I think that I had to keep up by posting every day,
Tôi có từng nghĩ răng tôi phải tiếp tục việc đăng bài mỗi ngày,
Or else, Instagram would banish me to the land of bad algorithms?
hay nếu không, tôi sẽ bị phạt bởi thuật toán của Instagram?
It was probably a mix of both, but here's what ended up happening
Nó có thể là sự kết hợp của cả hai, nhưng đây là những gì đã xảy ra
In the first 2 weeks, I shared a few photos and tweets,
Trong 2 tuần đầu, tôi đã chia sẻ một vài bức ảnh và trạng thái
But after I disrupted the feedback loop, I lost my drive to keep up and stop sharing.
Nhưng sau khi làm gián đoạn vòng lặp phản hồi, tôi không còn động lực để tiếp tục và ngừng việc chia sẻ.
I did continue to post videos to YouTube which I use as a platform, similar to a Blog.
Tôi đã vẫn tiếp tục đăng tải video lên YouTube – một nền tảng tương tự như Blog.
It doesn't have the same addictive effect as social media for me.
Nó có gây nghiện như mạng xã hội.
Or it does?
Hay không?
For the first week, I'd grab my phone without even thinking.
Tuần đầu, tôi liên tục chộp lấy điện thoại của mình mà không hề suy nghĩ
Unlock it and start to swipe through screens, looking for something to preoccupy my wandering mind.
Mở khóa và bắt đầu lướt màn hình, tìm kiếm thứ gì đó có thể khiến tâm trí lơ đãng của tôi bận tâm
Then I snapped back to reality and realize that
I had deleted all my social apps.
Sau đó, tôi nhận ra rằng mình đã xóa tất cả các ứng dụng xã hội rồi.
I started to spend much less time on my phone,
Tôi đã bắt đầu dùng điện thoại ít hơn,
Averaging 23 minutes of screen time per day.
Trung bình 23 phút mỗi ngày
Compared that to the previous month where I spent 98 minutes a day on my phone.
Trong khi tháng trước tôi dùng điện thoại tận 98 phút mỗi ngày.
Have you ever given the excuse "I don't have enough time to do ___."
Bạn đã bao giờ đưa ra lí do “tôi không có đủ thời gian để làm ...”
I know that I've definitely done it in the past.
Giống như tôi trước đây.
Whether you want to start reading more, go to the gym, or start a business.
Dù bạn muốn đọc sách, tập gym, hay bắt đầu kinh doanh.
A lot of times, we think we just simply don't have enough time to do it.
Rất nhiều lần, chúng ta nghĩ rằng chỉ đơn giản là chúng ta không có đủ thời gian để làm những điều gì đó.
When in fact, maybe it's our priorities that aren't really in check.
Trong khi thực tế, đó có lẽ là những việc ưu tiên mà chúng ta chưa hoàn thành
Maybe we need to think about where we're spending our time to begin with,
Có thể chúng ta nghĩ rằng đâu là nơi để bắt đầu dành thời gian,
Like social media.
Chẳng hạn như mạng xã hội.
Once you start to identify the things that you value in your life,
Một khi bạn xác định được những điều giá trị đối với cuộc sống,
The things you really want to bring into your life,
Những thứ bạn thật sự muốn xuất hiện trong cuộc đời mình,
You have to get rid of those distractions.
Bạn phải vượt qua những cám dỗ kia.
And for me at least it becomes social media.
Và đối với tôi, ít nhất đó là mạng xã hội.
And as for my business, did things slow down?
Nhưng đối với công việc kinh doanh của tôi, mọi thứ có đang trì trệ không?
Halfway through my 30-day detox, I saw the largest spike in subscribers on YouTube
Sau nửa chặng đường 30 ngày cai nghiện, tôi chứng kiến lượng người theo dõi trên YouTube tăng đột biến
That I've ever seen, like by far.
Điều tôi chưa từng thấy từ trước đến nay.
I have never even come close to seeing this kind of response for my videos.
Lần đầu tiên tôi nhận được những phản hồi như vậy trên những video của mình.
If you're wondering this is when I hit YouTube's trending page as a creator on the rise,
Nếu bạn đang thắc mắc, đây là thời điểm tôi đã trở thành người sáng tạo nội dung thịnh hành trên YouTube.
And this massive drop is when YouTube deleted a bunch of bot accounts.
Và điểm sụt giảm lớn này là khi YouTube xóa một loạt tài khoản bot.
I gained over 124,000 subscribers over the 30-day detox.
Hơn 124.000 người đã theo dõi tôi trong vòng 30 ngày cai nghiện.
The source of the traffic?
A video on my YouTube channel called "A Day in the Life of a Minimalist"
that quickly climbs to 3 million views in 10 days.
And as far as the revenue goes,
I got the biggest increase in patreon support since starting it in August.
Now I know what you're thinking:
"Matt, could you give us some more info about this patreon account
... like, I'm dying to know what you provide the patreon supporters?".
So I'll do that in about 30 seconds or so.
My patreon account is one of the ways
that I'm able to keep this YouTube channel 100% advertisement free.
And in exchange, I create exclusive content that I don't release anywhere else, covering
lifestyle design, how I make my videos and my personal vlog
In fact today I released a video breaking down
how I was able to grow my audience here on YouTube,
as well as provide advice and tips for those creators
who are looking to break through the noise.
You can get it all at patreon.com/mattdavella
but of course if you don't have the money to contribute right now,
do not feel pressured.
The fact that you watch my videos is enough from me.
So in the same month that I quit social media,
I saw exponential growth in my subscribers.
Trong cùng tháng tôi từ bỏ mạng xã hội, số lượng người đăng kí của tôi tăng theo cấp số nhân.
It's most likely a coincidence as I would have released that video anyway.
Đó có thể là sự trùng hợp vì dù sao tôi cũng đã phát hành video đó.
But it did make me think:
Nhưng nó khiến tôi  suy nghĩ:
"Why was I spending so much time on social media
when the heart of what I do is making films."
Tại sao tôi lại dành quá nhiều thời gian cho mạng xã hội
trong khi công việc chính của tôi là làm phim?
Seth Godin wrote an article this month called
Seth Godin đã viết 1 bài báo với tiêu đề
"Social media is a symptom, not a tactic".
“Mạng xã hội là 1 triệu chứng, không phải 1 chiến thuật”
In it he writes:
"The Mona Lisa has a huge social media presence"
Trong đó ông ấy đã viết “Mona Lisa có tầm ảnh hưởng lớn trên mạng xã hội”
Her picture is everywhere but she doesn't tweet.
Cô ấy xuất hiện khắp mọi nơi, nhưng cô ấy không “tweet”
She's big on social media because she's an icon.
Cô ấy nổi tiếng trên mạng xã hội vì cô ấy là một biểu tượng
But she's not an icon because she's big on social media
The negative of social media grooming is a seductive one.
Sử dụng mạng xã hội là điều gì đó vô cùng cám dỗ.
but it's as much of a dead-end at spending an extra hour,
picking out which tie to wear before giving a speech.
Nhưng hãy tưởng tượng liệu có đáng hay không việc bạn dành thêm 1 tiếng đồng hồ
chỉ để chọn ra chiếc cà vạt phù hợp với buổi thuyết trình.
With the additional hours every day, I was able to be a little bit more productive,
Với khoảng thời gian dư thừa, tôi có thể tận dụng để làm việc năng suất hơn
Which meant that I could get ahead with my work,
Chỉ tập trung vào công việc,
And I could either spend that on creating more content, more videos,
Cũng như sáng tạo thêm nhiều nội dung, nhiều video
Or I can just take some time off and spend it with my family.
Hoặc tôi có thể nghỉ ngơi và dành thời gian bên gia đình
Which is what I did when I went back home to visit them for about a week.
My nephew Oliver thought my Drone was the greatest thing ever.
The lesson? Productivity isn't always about increased output.
Another lesson? Don't give Oliver a Drone.
There's a sense of clarity that you get
when you take a step away from the compulsive checking.
Có một cảm giác rõ ràng mà bạn nhận được khi bạn rời khỏi mạng xã hội.
It's really hard to explain. It's really impossible to quantify.
Nó thực sự khó giải thích. Nó thực sự không thể định lượng được.
But I can tell you that I simply felt better by being away from it.
Nhưng tôi có thể nói với bạn rằng tôi chỉ đơn giản là cảm thấy tốt hơn khi rời xa nó.
And it became much harder for me to see the benefits of social media to begin with.
Và nó trở nên khó khăn cho tôi hơn để thấy được những lợi ích của mạng xã hội để bắt đầu.
The urge to get back on Instagram and apps like it is mostly fueled by the fear of missing out.
Sự thôi thúc quay trở lại Instagram và các ứng dụng giống như nó phần lớn được thúc đẩy bởi nỗi sợ bỏ lỡ.
For some reason, we've convinced ourselves that it's important,
that it's necessary.
Vì lý do nào đó, chúng tôi tự thuyết phục rằng điều đó là quan trọng, là cần thiết.
But once I got connected again, I realized one simple truth:
Nhưng khi đã kết nối lại, tôi nhận ra một sự thật đơn giản:
I didn't miss a thing.
Tôi không bỏ lỡ điều gì cả.
Now looking ahead to my next 30 days as a solo creator
Hướng đến 30 ngày tới với tư cách là người sáng tạo nội dung độc lập
And someone with a finite number of hours in the day.
Và một người có số giờ hữu hạn trong ngày.
I'm not so sure I want to spend them the way I used to.
Tôi không chắc mình muốn sử dụng chúng như trước đây.
Sign up for Patreon.com for dozen unlisted videos with new ones coming every month.
And of course subscribe to my channel for new videos every week.
Thanks for watching!